this podcast is brought to you by on it
go to honor.com and look at the great
selection of supplements if you find
something you like
pressing code joey and get 10 off
delivered right to your house what's
happening you bad [ __ ] the
joint is brought to you by
and i want to welcome them to the
podcast fit by it could be
hard to find time to work out fit bod
tail is an exercise program to your
goals equipment and schedule
it's easiest way to work out
the video tutorials make it easy to
learn a new routine
and it varies your routine for you so
you don't have to over train way cheaper
than a personal trainer you can get a
full year personalized workout with
fitbot for less than the cost of one
session with a personal trainer fitbot
is easy to use on both apple and android
devices keep your workout momentum going
or get started get personalized workouts
from fitbot that get tougher as you do
get 25 off your subscription or try the
app for free when you sign up now at
dot me slash joey again
fit bod dot me
slash joey that's twenty five percent
off your subscription or try it for free
at fitbit
dot me slash joey i suggest you giving
it the free trial and you're going to be
impressed
fit bob will work you out like a dog
jack so right now
go to fitbit dot me slash joey and get
25
off the joint is also brought to you by
giraffe kings listen last week
was action-packed and it's just getting
started
get ready for week two of touchdowns
tackles and even bigger wins with
draftkings sportsbook an official sports
betting partner of the nfl this week
again new customers
just bet five hours on a football game
and i'll get you 203 bets instantly you
want more action i got more action
everyone can experience the thrill of
draftkings early win promotion it's
simple this sunday you bet on any nfl
team to win if your team leads by 10 any
point of the game you get paid instantly
even if your team
loses so do me a favor right now and do
yourself a favor download the draftking
sportsbook app now today use promo code
joey j-o-e-y
to get 203 bets instantly when you place
a five dollar bet on any football team
don't forget we still got baseball we
still got college football so draftkings
is your fountain
the an official sports betting partner
of the nfl
minimum age and eligibility restrictions
apply
see show notes for details now do me a
favor
download the draftking sportsbook app
and go win some [ __ ] money
[Music]
welcome to uncle joey's joy
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
what's happening you bad [ __ ]
it's wednesday i got my main man
brian callan here i got him to come down
to [ __ ] marlborough new jersey to
talk some [ __ ] for an hour what's
happening brother it's good to be here
man it is good great to see you miss you
i miss you i miss you too yeah i was
looking i was looking for the
because i have it i still have it i just
couldn't it's in the wrong notebook i
was looking for the worksheet
from the acting
for the beverly hills playhouse no we
did the one we did that we did you see
we did this we kept it a secret from
rogan yes we didn't say that because he
would have made we took an acting
seminar it cost us 350 bucks each and he
had found out about that [ __ ] i see him
it's like a drug deal i see him i go
what are you doing he goes i'm gonna
hear you guys
i go well don't tell rogue [ __ ]
he wouldn't understand but you know they
were trying to be actors this had to be
2001 oh yeah we studied
we started acting in earnest we studied
it in earnest
and i forget this is the guy that cast
sleepers
and he cast godfather two oh yeah he did
all he cast john donnie brasco and and
milton cazales who had directed betty
davis in butterflies are free to an
oscar the people that we used to be in
his class burt reynolds would drop in
[ __ ] you know uh neil simon the great
playwright would just show up
bro anthony hopkins would come in and
just like where was this at this was at
the beverly hills playhouse at this
at the class i'd get up on stage at on a
saturday class doris roberts emmy
award-winning [ __ ] actress from
everybody loves raymond giovanni rabisi
i mean you name it people like those
that like the biggest names in hollywood
are in the class so when you get up on
stage you better bring some [ __ ]
money you better you better be prepared
the first time i did a [ __ ] scene
i've got graduated into the master class
whatever the [ __ ] it is
and uh milton concells goes uh it was
good good very facile you know how do
you think you did i said i don't know
you know i'm not good at this i did all
right he goes no no you did very well
you know what the problem is i said what
he goes everybody behind me can do
exactly the same thing so what are you
gonna do to be different than that
and that began the journey and that's
why i'm an international star now
now beverly hills playhouse yeah beverly
hills playhouse
was the one that you had to sign up for
two years and you weren't allowed to
audition
well it was a place where you started
there were tears
to it
and you you had inter you had a beginner
intermediate advanced master class all
that [ __ ]
and it got a whole bunch of flak because
it was scientology
if you read going clear about
scientology that lawrence wright wrote
the class features
heavily
i did benefits at the scientology center
for 9 11. i didn't know i didn't give a
[ __ ] i didn't know anything about
science i don't give a [ __ ] i'm not
going to get brought into it
and a lot of the scientific colleges i
knew were cool people i mean i did
kirsty alley's show and she was the
scientist was shot there because she was
a big scientist but you know that was
that was why it got mentioned in that
book
because milton gonzalez was a he was
clear he'd reached clarity
what a [ __ ] brilliant thing yeah
but then he left
and when he left it became this whole
[ __ ] thing it's crazy how they had
all those little acting things going on
when we got to la and they're still
there but since we're not into it we
don't know what's going on you know why
because you get to a certain age and
maybe it's for a new york thing like if
you're going to come at me with a whole
new philosophy bro i'm like hey listen
teach me how to act the [ __ ] out of here
with all the rest of it now where did
you actually learn how to act in new
york city yeah i mean you know i i
started out i took some classes in
college
and i said to myself [ __ ] this is uh
that i couldn't see a linear
progression
right if you want to be a great olympic
athlete there's a you want to be a
professional football player there are
tiers there there are stop gaps
you either make it in d1 or you don't
you either distinguish yourself in d1
you get drafted in the sixth round or
the first round you know you then you
whatever it is you got to make that team
so you you have these stop gaps acting
you can just be like i'm talented cause
my mother told me i was and then and
then you're 44 years old you wake up you
got no resume how many people do we know
like that so so i i kind of saw that and
i was like i don't want to be that guy
so i stopped and i decided i was going
to be a banker
yeah
and then i realized then i go oh i'm
going to i'm going to put a gun in my
mouth this is a [ __ ] i can't do this
[ __ ] i'm wearing a tie and silk stocks
have taken the [ __ ]
the path from hoboken new jersey into to
work at the accounts receivable payables
division no windows at lehman brothers
get the [ __ ] out of here okay
and i woke up from a nap and i got to be
an actor so i went to the the
neighborhood playhouse in new york city
on 54th street
and uh that was the first time i went
this might be the only thing i'm made
for then i then i found comedy
stand up but you know what i mean like i
i was like i think that i'm not good at
anything and i might be good at being
somewhat emotional and real
because i could feel it i was i was i
was uh my my childhood had been so
chaotic that i was able to kind of
it helped me and i was also a daydreamer
i was also [ __ ] i wanted to be i've
always wanted to be anybody but me yeah
me too right yeah we all do we all you
know what i'm saying so i was like i
don't like who i am so i was always
fantasizing about being taller stronger
faster [ __ ] scottish english whatever
the [ __ ] it was and all of a sudden i
saw you can make a living that way
and so then i went to but then then you
come out of theater school and now now
you got to compete and i'm like i don't
know
i looked in the mirror and i went
there's nothing about me physically
they're not going to be like that oh
these white medium
you know like i might joke because i
could pick your pocket in the [ __ ]
in a parade and you who are you gonna
what are you gonna tell the cops he was
brown hair white medium i blend in bro i
look like i look like every other guy
medium so that's why i got understanding
but patty jenkins
who is the writer director of monster
wonder woman she's supposed to do i
think she's doing star wars big director
but i used to date her back in the day
20 years ago and she said she looked at
me she goes hey you hey stop trying to
be de niro and walking you're not a
brooding
deep actor you're a you're a jackass you
make all of us laugh
stand up comedy she's the reason she
took me to see she goes we're going to
watch some comedy it happened i'm at the
new york comedy club who's up on stage i
don't know greg geraldo louis ck dave
attel monsters
and i i've never done it i'm doing this
all the time
i'm biting my nails i'm so over i'm so
overwhelmed with how i'm so overwhelmed
with how funny they are and i'm like i
can never it's like i'll never do this
now before you go any further yeah
how do you feel about not being a deep
actor
i could give a [ __ ] like me
listen to me
this is the truth
and i had to i came to terms with this
i'm 55 years old i came to turn this
about a year ago two years ago i've
never been on set
i've never been on set
where i didn't want it to be over
it's like eating a salad like i ate a
salad because in the back of my mind i
think well i'll eat this [ __ ] salad
that's [ __ ] but i'll maybe i won't
die of cancer you know right early right
right i'm not going to restaurants
because they got good salads
i'm an american you understand i'm going
i'm going to [ __ ] i'm going i'm going
to [ __ ] restaurants because they got
steak chocolate and cheese
i want all the things that are bad for
me and i want wine i'm not going there
because i've never gone they have really
good vegetables the side vegetables and
the salads are amazing the [ __ ] out of
here
so it's the same idea i realized that
the process of acting the non-linear
progression of it
and the process of it like just waking
up early the makeup and then having to
be on set hurry up and wait you if
you're doing a film you're shooting a
page a day
what
i ca i don't have it bob i don't have it
i i was on the set of joker i watched
that maniac win an oscar
for four days i'm like i could never do
what this guy does he can stay in
character the whole time not talk to
anybody
no no give me stand up bro i like
working an hour maybe two hours and
that's a lot for me a day the rest of
the time i like it all oh yeah well
you're good at all you're very good no
no no no no no no come on
i liked it all like
right now i have to do another audition
i have to put another audition on tape
and for the first time in years
i'm excited oh really i'm excited what's
the project can you say it's a de niro
movie but it's with uh that's different
barry
i never had a chance to work with harry
the director is barry
goldwater no
the dude who did rain man and a bunch
here levinson barry levinson that's a
bad [ __ ] so well now you're
talking about a whole different level
that's what i'm storytelling so i'm not
a [ __ ] deep
like when i don't have to go in another
room and
breathe and you know you know what you
are you're an original well
it's great but it doesn't get you far
when you want to aspire as like a good
actor yeah you know
yeah listen yeah you're not doing the
daniel day-lewis [ __ ]
i've heard this before that
mitzi mitzi would always talk to me on
sunday nights and she said to me
why are you going to act in class
this is the best acting class you could
get
and she goes this is why people
don't want to work with stand-up comics
like harrison ford and all these people
and she was and i agree with that yeah
and the original room will get your
timing better than anything in the world
your timing is [ __ ]
dead on but for some reason i always
feel like when i'm on a film
like when i shot the money saints in
newark there was a lot of dudes in that
movie who were traditional actors
they make six figures from doing
acting they
bought a house from doing acting
we could have done that too if we had
more
there's like they have to push you if we
didn't fall in love with stand up
right well that was and we can also do
stand-up well i fell in love with
stand-up before i was always a movie
buff but i never thought i could
reach it
yeah i was like the number's going to
hire me i know a [ __ ] movie okay i'm
gonna be an extra
maybe
maybe and that's what a capital [ __ ]
and yeah maybe yeah i'm being extra in
the background that healthy dose of
self-loathing and the feeling of total
insignificance of course listen as
americans we've been taught that they're
everything that's right you know i came
to this country when they were
everything that's right uh charles
bronson well they were royalty they were
royalty
they were out of touch elvis was [ __ ]
everything out of touch you know [ __ ]
uh you know when you look at somebody
like elvis yeah i've been watching that
movie lately just [ __ ] like
remembering how good
of an entertainer that man was like what
he did yeah was [ __ ] uh you know you
can't even yeah and you look at it now
and you go he's elvis no [ __ ] put
yourself in 1955
and his voice oh everything look dope he
could be on the he could be on the voice
right now and everybody does this vocal
gymnastics that guy would [ __ ] he'd
bring it to your knees
he'd bring you the ears he would right
yes he could sing anything in the ghetto
any of that [ __ ] give him what do you
want him to sing pick a number bro that
guy that he'll do
correct and kill you with a bally an
athlete that's the way he danced an
athlete that's deadly he could kill you
with a ballad or just [ __ ] you up yes he
had an array of hits what do you mean
like jailhouse rock listen to his voice
listen to that jesus christ he's like
the male adele but better that's my
[ __ ] song right there he comes out
it's still astonishing it really is it's
still a style it still holds
up you listen that and you're like i
want what happens when you watch as you
go i want to i one time in my life i
want to just sing that song i want to be
that guy
i want to be i want to have that [ __ ]
voice and loud he was singing jailhouse
he was yelling into that [ __ ] thing
it just i you know i had dinner with the
guy who wrote that song
oh my god yeah
and and uh quiet quiet jewish guy from
new york or wherever i think gay
and uh he wrote love me tender he wrote
jailhouse rock yeah he's a giant i
didn't realize i was sitting next to him
and i i mean i couldn't i almost threw
myself at his feet because nobody else
understood i'm like hey hey hey we got
to stop everything sometimes you got to
stop everything yeah i agree with you
and give it up you know
fall at the man's feet because it's
worth it
and uh but i mean that you it's like you
hear jailhouse rock it's a little bit
like hearing cashmere by zeppelin it
never gets old
what is it about some artistic
expression that never gets old
you just never get tired of it
it's
you know it's crazy but no that's who i
grew up around
like i see the actors that are winning
oscars today yeah and i see the act the
oscar winners from when i was younger
and i was really into film
there's not even a comparison there's
not even a [ __ ] compassion and mitzi
is wrong though about one thing which is
that acting is technique there there is
a great deal of technique there are
there are things that a good director
and a good teacher who teaches the craft
of acting it's a craft
it's it's making the unconventional
choice
it's it's it's you know it's like um
it's a lot scarier like a good acting
teacher like jeffrey tambor my teacher
[ __ ] bad [ __ ]
jeffrey tambor the guy with the bald
head yeah yeah the old dude yes that was
on like he was on transparent he was on
right he's a monster yeah yeah
unbelievable
he was my acting teacher for a [ __ ]
seven years bro
that dude that dude could teach you some
[ __ ] where is he he's hiding he's
probably now he's probably he's got it
he's got another project he does what he
wants
but he's like that's a real actor that
dude's an actor to his core and that guy
you came in and said if the line is i'm
gonna kill you
he would say well that's not
how you do it
you might just want to
smile at him
i'm going to kill you
that's a lot scary all of a sudden you
go oh wait a minute bro whoa i never
thought of it doing that wasn't he in
the professional not the professor no no
no he wasn't that's the accountant he
was an injustice for all remember the
guy throwing plates in injustice for all
if you see him bring him up i don't know
if you have a thing if you see him you'd
see who the [ __ ] i'm talking about but
disney that isn't
jeffrey he might be in the accountant
yes he plays the
old accountant for the mob that makes
sense and he teaches john bernthal how
to
jump right no uh
you know do all that [ __ ] yeah but no we
didn't i didn't see it i fell in love
with stand up
and
i always had the notion of acting and
then when i got hired
i joined i was part of an acting class
on
schrader no no gardner
right behind
uh oh yeah in in l.a yeah yeah right
behind a sunset grill yeah right in that
if you go down that block who was
teaching it
frank something great guy
great guy knew his [ __ ]
hated me when i he found that i was
friends with andrew diceclat
just [ __ ] turned on me like told me
ready yeah he told me like he was like
because i had to leave on monday nights
oh okay class was like monday we were
opening for dice or something no monday
nights was like the big night in la when
i got there in 97 it was
latin latino night at the laugh factory
open mic at the comedy store but freaky
monday
at the improv and freaky monday was
tremendous so every monday i would have
to either go to latino uh to the ice
house i would have to go to the lab
factory or the improv so class would
start at seven so i go in there
alert till about 8 15 and go hey
i got to get out of here
and he would lose his mind where are you
going i got to do some comedy okay and
then one night he asked me he goes uh
when you go down to the comedy store
who's down there
and i said something to him like andrew
dice clay or something like on monday
nights
and he was like do you know him and i go
yeah i talked to him once in a while you
know and he was like
good to know he's a piece of [ __ ] and he
just started going off
because he just didn't like his uh i
found out later
years later i bumped into him his wife
died
so i sent him like a note
and he told me that you know uh
he had hired him for
something and then
he didn't do you know andrew's crazy
didn't do the pitch with him so he
wasted time and all this [ __ ] and that
was it yeah i went to that place and
then i went to
with everybody on my back i went to
advanta chubby
oh yeah very good teacher very good i
met her and had a little correspondence
with her because she saw me do stand-up
once
and i had a long talk with her she's
she's the real good lady no good lady
listen man charlize theron she helped a
lot of mother charlize and the other
girl
she has a long list of very successful
actors but she won two oscars in a row
yeah the girl who won it before you know
what charlize throne and and the girl
who was in uh million dollar baby right
uh um her and the black girl
um the african-american halle berry
halle berry there you go and i remember
that going to that class it was the same
thing you have to start in beginner
and uh the guy liked me and i know you
know what started happening i started
booking yeah i actually after i joined
the class like after four weeks i
started booking and he was like what's
going on with you i'm like i'm booking
[ __ ]
whatever you're teaching me it's working
you know that's what happened to me
you start booking in class you start
booking you know and it's really weird
because everybody else is worried about
scenes
yeah like you're not gonna believe this
i have the scene from
back then when we were coming up
if you got a job on a tv show it wasn't
like today if you got a job on a tv show
the world knew your name and you were
gonna buy a house like you made money
people see what people don't realize and
correct me if i'm wrong nobody was
making money doing stand-up you didn't
have social media you couldn't curate
your own audience if you were making
five grand a weekend that was a [ __ ]
fortune nobody i remember when zach
galifianakis told me he was making he
whispered to me he goes i'm making ten
thousand dollars i went what the
stand up nobody was making money
like now you can curate your own
audience you're making 10 million
dollars a year and you've been in the
game for five years
back then you did stand up because maybe
you'd get a [ __ ] sitcom and you could
eat well and have a house you know you
had that dream like if you got if you
got like any time if you got anything
like a will and grace or a friends get
the [ __ ] you'd hear these stories it's
like i'm going to buy a porsche you know
for me it was like i get to drink really
good wine you know the whole [ __ ]
thing it was never about the art but but
you know what i'm saying and pilot
season and that there'd be there'd be a
small number of slots and you had to
compete with that [ __ ]
i remember booking like
my first pilot
i was ready to buy a house bro with no
money
and it was an hour drama for cbs and
they gave the director a million dollars
to direct it and they're like when i was
shooting it they're like dog this is
gone this is you guys will go buy a
lamborghini and [ __ ] i'm like come on
say that to you like come on guys
and i didn't say a word like i was old
enough alright i was every pilot that's
ever been shot they say that every pilot
35 i remember when i heard about friends
that the [ __ ] writer from
friends gave each of those six
[ __ ]
no he gave him 500 bucks and he said
walk to the casino when they shot the
pilot for friends after the pilot he
goes
walk through the casino
this will be the last time you'll be
able to walk through a casino
wow
wow
without getting wow
that's cool
that is [ __ ] crazy that's pretty cool
but i've seen a lot of dudes come and go
and i've seen a lot of guys buy [ __ ]
they couldn't afford it's like my buddy
gets a series i never forgot this and
and like he goes you got to see my new
house
so i come in and i look at the house
and he's doing a series now i've been in
the game for a while and i look at the
house and i swear to god i went like
this i look at him i go
how much this house cost he goes about
1-6 i go 1-6 i go what'd you put down he
goes uh 20
so i know the math right away because
i've been i i go i look at him i go
you're gonna make forty five thousand
dollars before you wake up in the
morning right he goes yeah a little more
i go
and i remember going
you're gonna [ __ ] you're gonna be out
of this house in six months
i call them up six months later i go how
you doing because i'm turning into the
skid and go bro
yeah
because your series didn't go
because it didn't go because it never
goes and you got yourself leveraged you
can't buy the house before you have the
money in the bank i don't know how many
actors i saw do that
because they're actors and because you
think it's going to keep going
back then you could do that back then
you could get you can get a mortgage
it's [ __ ] crazy bro i have a list i
could sit here give me a week and i'll
have a hundred names of people dumb damn
it up so you know the guy who he bought
a rolls-royce he got a development deal
out of montreal six months later he's
living in the [ __ ] car
and that's a true story that guys and
this is
this is it and people have no
idea i could i could sit here give me a
week and we could do a podcast again
yeah just like you know they read the
911 names on sunday we could just read
the [ __ ] names of people who just
[ __ ] booked the pilot lost their
minds you'd be there all day oh my god
guys i i this is such a great topic
because i could go for hours with this
oh yeah and this is how you learn when
you see people actually
crumble like guys there was one guy one
year in montreal i do not know what his
name was this has to be 2003. yeah
went up to montreal good looking he
looked like [ __ ]
superman before he fell off the horse
what's his name christopher reeves
he looked beaut this man was beautiful
dawg
he walked into the car i'll never forget
he walked into the comedy store like a
tuesday night
he had six jews with him you know agents
with suits on
that's when agents did [ __ ] with you
like eight of them well it was all the
mafia you had saw the mafia you had to
have a manager and an agent he had
everybody yeah you're gonna see a third
of your check
that's how it was a third of your check
[ __ ] you're amazing if you're making 7
500 bucks a week which i was on mad tv i
saw i don't know how it happened 1500
bucks i don't know where the [ __ ] the
money went bro i'd be like how the [ __ ]
it's 1500 my dad was like what the [ __ ]
are you doing i'm not doing anything i
got a business manager a business
manager yeah they told me they all talk
to each other
a third of my money i'm a [ __ ] you
know it's guys it's
it's crazy out
oh my god i saw a guy next to me by a
porsche
with his stripper girlfriend we lived in
a [ __ ]
one-bedroom apartment next to me called
wishful thinking it's called optimus oh
my god and i wouldn't buy [ __ ] when i
could shot that pilot
they were telling me all these numbers
i think the number for me was 18 five i
couldn't even oh bro i couldn't a week
yeah that's so much money that was a 15
000 a week that's so much when i booked
the pilot the agent at the pilot goes we
have to call them back and get a
uh i'll never forget this because they
gave me 25 000 just to move here
wow okay so they gave me twenty five
thousand but i was minus
two hundred thousand so don't cry i
don't want people to go you got twenty
five thousand first of all twenty five
thousand after an agent an attorney is
[ __ ] twenty about twelve grand it's
about twelve yeah it's about 12 grams
just figure that out that's a fact so
when i moved down here they were like
okay you know you're going to get i
don't know what it was for the pilot i i
have no idea maybe 1500 or something
like that but then the agent goes we
have to call and get your quote for the
uh for this and what they don't know is
we do it for [ __ ] free we do it i
would do it for free though
this was like that who played the doctor
on the sopranos when he when uh
what's his name went to prison
at the end of the sopranos yeah i
remember at the end the guy from the
other family johnny sack goes to prison
and there's a doctor there he was also
in
yeah he befriends a doctor with glasses
that's what they paid a million dollars
to direct wow he was also on eyes wide
shut he's the one that's oh
man
sydney [ __ ] was directing that thing
when they when cbs pays sydney pollock
took a million dollars to direct yeah
that show's going yeah that show's going
that's what you're saying so when i shot
the pilot i went from 10 pages of
verbage yeah to one because i didn't
know how to act
so every day i went in i lost the page
and then towards the end they just had
me like grunting and like making noises
at the end people really never talked to
me they were like you know it's gonna
all work out you weren't ready you
weren't ready no i wasn't [ __ ] ready
i never acted in my life before they
threw me on a cbs pilot
so i [ __ ] like on the way home
they're like it's gonna be okay don't
when you get back then then exactly just
to listen get an acting class
immediately yeah i'll visit with you and
i'm like
this sucks but i'm like man i can't wait
to buy that house and the fact i went
all the way to miami that's after they
towed my car and i went all the way to
miami for three weeks because i didn't
want to even think about it
i did not want to think about it i was
going to get the call that the pilot got
picked up i was going to call the drug
dealer get a [ __ ] kilo or coke and
just go to my room and slaughter and
then start shooting the [ __ ] episode
because they were going to give me 18
000 [ __ ] week for and those days you
picked up i think it was 16 episodes
right off the bat yeah that's right
which by the way is crazy it's [ __ ]
crazy you're set
i was gonna get 18 0018 five for 16
episodes from september to december and
then come back and shoot another 16 or
whatever the [ __ ] it was 17 episodes
at 18 000 so guys yes
when i got the call i was in miami and
jeff gatlin called me my ex manager he
goes hey
i don't know how to tell you this and
i'm like what i didn't get the travolta
project because i was going to get a
travel movement he said it didn't get
picked up he goes the pilot didn't get
picked up and i'm like what the [ __ ] are
you saying
what the [ __ ] i was like possible sydney
pollock
they called me when i got back to l.a
he's like it's going to be a mid-season
replacement
oh
so i was like okay so
i called the director the
executive producer he's like yeah we're
going to get together in a couple weeks
and start writing scripts again because
we'll probably be on tv by december or
january
no
and it was [ __ ] uh
that was it was that's the story of my
that's but that's 18 000.
and then do you remember when when i was
gonna get the do you remember the
beginning of reality rogan got fear
factor on nbc
and i was in new york with him i'm gonna
forget this i'm in new york on times
square he goes into a [ __ ] place to
buy a samurai
like there was a six-foot samurai
standing on broadway which with blue
eyes he's so crazy with a [ __ ] sword
so [ __ ] weird he's like i'm going in
there
to pay for this statue and i go i don't
want to go in there i don't like him he
spent money in those days i got he
always he had always had the confidence
he's got two houses in my pocket and
he's buying a statue for 1200. i'm like
forget the statue i'll go in front of
the house and pose like that just give
me
just give me 200 right now for the day
something i'll never forget we were he
was in the thing
and i was standing on broadway and above
me was that rotating thing yeah and it
said fear factor you know yeah america
yeah this show and he was walking out
talking to me on broadway and that
didn't matter no it didn't matter ten
people running to me going are you big
[ __ ] from the sopranos we want to get a
picture i'm like that's joe rogan from
fairfax like [ __ ] him yeah and i'm like
oh my god that's how crazy that's how it
goes and with with joe i remember him
getting famous and i remember when we
were in new york city and a cop goes joe
rogan because he was doing fear factor
and i went my boys and then the guys oh
[ __ ] joe rogan and i went bro you're
famous and then he bought that that
house
up in uh buckingham bell canyon
and
i'd known him you know i mean we were
he'd been a guest on mad tv i'd been
against and we're sitting there and he
said something so great he was looking
he's standing there like this and i'm
looking at his [ __ ] house with the
marble floors and the [ __ ] view and
then i go bro i go you're rich and
famous like what's it like and he goes
it feels exactly the same except for my
walls are a little more farther apart so
my dogs aren't as close to me
oh what a great buck and i'm like he
understood the illusion
that fame and money is like it's good to
have but at the end of the day he goes
yeah my walls are farther apart and that
just means that there's more space so
the things i love have to get to me it
takes them longer to get he was thinking
mathematically and
geogra metrically i'm like this
[ __ ] thinks on a different level
you know but he's kind of right i
remember dave the day he called me when
he said i'm quitting acting
35 years old i go what
what do you mean quitting acting back
then it's like you can't make a living
doing stand-up i mean you can make some
money but not you know you're not
quitting i don't want to [ __ ] act i
don't want some guy telling me what to
do i don't [ __ ] like it i don't like
the people everybody's got a hole they
can't fill so [ __ ] it i'm like i
remember just being like all right
you're [ __ ] crazy and he stuck to it
and it worked for him things are good
and you don't want the kid and you don't
want him yeah and you know what's crazy
man that's the problem
and it was a problem for me
the only problem i really had
was
listen you love doing stand-up but you
also know
sometimes for people stand up is uh
means to an end there was not that for
me
i know i know i saw a lot of people in
la
move towel i got on a tv show
you never saw them on the stage ever
again
no you never saw them no
it kind of bothered me it didn't it kind
of bothered me like i mean you still see
it though a lot of people are getting
into everybody's stand-up now
well now it's going the other way around
now it's going back to being a stand-up
because listen
a stand-up comic today i mean i'm
surprised we don't have baseball cards
i'm really surprised
well but joey like here's what i say
about stand-up
there are very few people
who
you can take
and throw in like everybody says they're
a comic but
nowadays you can curate your own
audience so before you can get up there
everybody loves you it's like it's like
performing for your own family in a
living room when you're a kid
but there are very few comics and you're
one of these guys
i can put you up in front of any [ __ ]
audience anywhere in the world they
don't know you they've never heard of
you
and i'm and i give you 45 minutes up
there and you got them laughing for the
whole 45 minutes
that's a that's a rare fraternity that
is a small group of people
because that takes real skill and it
takes a long [ __ ] time
i think that's lost on it
and if we were bankers
the headliners all of us who are
headliners if we were bankers we'd be
very very wealthy because there's
probably how many people can do that
honestly who can put out hour after hour
that does really well where we've been
making people laugh for 25 years on that
level not a lot of people bro i always
say you come to my friend's show come to
my show come to my friend's show
you'll laugh harder by far than any
movie you've ever seen in your life put
it up there hangover whatever come to a
joey diaz show come to a [ __ ] joe
rogan show come to a bill burr show come
to a sebastian maniscalco show come to a
steve burns show where whoever the [ __ ]
it is sam tripoli
you'll laugh harder
for one hour than you'll ever laugh at a
movie that's rare error man that's not
easy
speaking of which man tears on youtube
guys am i special make sure you get that
run run but it's free just do that
so you tape the special way
pray improv
great place yeah
unbelievable great and sam
dana
dana who is sam tripley's gal she's the
one who produced it did an amazing job i
paid for the whole thing myself and i
just put it up there and russell peters
said call it man tears because it's
really about vulnerability and how men
can't cry
and it's [ __ ] you know and so far
getting a lot of love so we'll see when
did you put it up i put it up six days
ago and how's it going it's good you
know over 300 000 views and and counting
it's crazy how much stand up
has changed again in the last covert
has changed stand up it's changed acting
um yeah
you also got to be you're you're in a
tick-tock world
so you got to be putting out
you know
pieces and pieces every day because
people are consuming comedy now like
it's candy
you know beyonce was saying nobody wants
to see a body of work
like they'll tell you you my special is
50 minutes the truth is most people get
through 27 minutes it doesn't matter who
the [ __ ] you are the truth i don't care
if you're chappelle i don't care i don't
care rogan
people get through maybe 25 minutes
and they they'll watch it in pieces so
you so putting out 50 minutes
you know that's a gamble i got to break
it up because that's just the way it is
and it used to be you put out an hour
see see the channels man we're so
predictable put out an hour i got all my
people i got my team they're gonna do
all that [ __ ] one of the good things is
now it's up to us
now i now i i'm producer i'm publisher
i'm director i do it all i'm on my own
pr team i don't need pr
i do this podcast i do flagrant i do
that that's that's more than any pr any
magazine magazine what do you want me to
do kimmel the [ __ ] out of here for three
minutes nah no thanks i'll do this
you know you know what i mean have you
seen the numbers saturday night live
gets
those actors can't sell tickets god
bless them they're all very talented but
it's hard
it's not enough just to be on a tv show
so new media is you know it's really
crazy how much you're right when we got
that lane 97 you recurred on a tv show
that's it seven episodes you sold out
all your shows and you did that until
the show
ended you know right nick apollo did it
with grace under fire it was just
[ __ ] i was on goldbergs for seven
years bro they gave me my own tv show
i've sold exactly three tickets as a
result of that show he gives a [ __ ]
nobody gives a [ __ ] do rogan once and
you sell out you sell out
it's really unreal how much
and i did a podcast maybe about a year
ago
and i spoke about
how
agents aren't building comics up anymore
to get a tv show
it's not happening when i got into
comedy the three biggest shows that the
comedy comedians ever did were on
roseanne
uh that year that they tim allen
they gave uh tom rhodes a special not a
special tv show they gave the korean
girl margaret cho one and somebody else
oh greg corrado that you were talking
about
we had a period where
the networks were like [ __ ] it we got an
easier we're gonna do what they did with
roseanne and tim allen just do a comedy
do a series derived from their stand-up
comedy
and it was working yeah it was working
they canceled tom rhodes they cancelled
uh whatever but you know listen have you
sign 10 comics three of them are gonna
make it yeah the other seven are gonna
fizzle away and guess what they still
have a career that opens up a door for
you
but today we don't have that even up to
20 years ago we had ray romano we had a
bunch of guys on tv today we don't and
i'm gonna tell you why
it's not because the agents aren't
building
is because the comics are saying why the
[ __ ] am i gonna do that
why would i want to go on a set
take orders all [ __ ] day
now with rules
you know a comic is not
gonna adjust to those rules you can't
say [ __ ] on those sets
you can't say anything on those sets you
can't even crack a joke
and the money can't crack a joke no you
can't cry
and the money sucks at the end of the
day the money sucks and
you're working with the creepiest
[ __ ] people in [ __ ] hollywood i
mean let me give you an example i own a
flip-flop company to hold i bring joe
some toe holds you know because
this is the reach think about this now
i'm terrible at self promotion and
plugging so i'm i'm plugging my brand
right because i you know i own 30 of the
company so i go i'm going to bring rogan
a pair and i'm going to talk i'm wearing
my toe holds [ __ ] eddie bravo's
wearing we're doing the fight companion
i'm going to talk about my [ __ ]
company i'm not i don't know i'm not a
business guy i'm not making money but i
just [ __ ] i'm like i'm going to try
to be a businessman very clumsy i'm
terrible about it but but but but rogan
all he did was this he takes the pair of
flip-flops
now listen to this and he goes because
he's making fun of me for even like
pushing michael put your toe holds on he
goes [ __ ] you stop trying to plug your
[ __ ] your flip-flops and but then he
picks them up and he goes but they are
the best-made flip-flops on the planet
because they're expensive they're the
most expensive but they're handmade and
[ __ ] with the best leather we [ __ ] i
mean you can get everything i'm gonna
send you a pair do you wear flip-flops
no all right so never mind you would
wear this but anyway so there but he
does this all he does is this he goes
they are the best made flip-flops you
can't even pull them apart and he goes
like this he goes it's like they're
they're unbelievable they're they're
incredibly made and he does this that's
it okay we're done they go you got your
[ __ ] plug you plugged it you're happy
just off of that
just off of that after him saying that
we have i believe 60 000 more followers
on the toehold instagram
on the 60 000.
we had in two days 20 000 people visit
the [ __ ] website we had to shut it
down because we were selling too many
rash guards too many flip-flops and too
many [ __ ] t-shirts
because the guy makes them by hand these
flip-flops and we gotta we gotta we had
to hire new people to make these
flip-flops there are 350 bucks a pair
they're the best flip-flops on the
planet they'll last you forever but the
[ __ ] all of a sudden he's like i
got to stop this with 20 000 people off
of one [ __ ] mention from that guy
find me the tv show
find me the sitcom find me the news
organization where you could do that
where a guy goes like that he goes yeah
these are the best made flip flops on
the planet and does this that's it boom
and by the way still going on we're
getting crashed it's like he's like he's
like [ __ ] they we sold out of the rash
guards we sold out of the [ __ ]
t-shirt they i know but i mean that that
was that was that was all we needed
you know it's like well holy crap that's
a different way of do you understand
like if you have a business that's do a
podcast the right one and somebody like
that just says hey these are the best
made flip-flops on the planet
your how much would that cost two
million dollars three million dollars to
get that kind of effect
i mean i think literally we went from
think about the accounts on instagram
sixty thousand people new followers
we got it's a it's it's a [ __ ] it's
told it's a flip-flop thing and we got
we got over 300 000 followers
other companies are calling us going how
the [ __ ] do you have this many followers
how are you getting this kind of
interaction i don't know i go on
podcasts i talk about it i did it once
on rogan well did you see this thing
came out about three weeks ago
that people are paying to go on podcasts
of course they are they're paying big
money forty thousand they should 20 000
so they can explore who they are or
their product or whatever the [ __ ] at
first i stay i'm like that sounds a
little [ __ ] cool it's a catch you
can't be that guy right what do you mean
i don't want nobody coming on my path
guys that's what i mean i can't do it
i get those offers i can't i can't i
cannot do something i don't believe in
i'm not going to have you on
my the fans would be like hey bro get
the [ __ ] out of here we we tune in
because you guys are having an honest
conversation even plug and to hold like
when i when i talk about it i get [ __ ]
people like hey [ __ ] you in your
flip-flops you know and they should i
get it
you know i get it i understand because
it's like nobody wants to be sold we're
all being sold i come to a podcast to
[ __ ] have a conversation i come to a
podcast to listen just to have a good
time yeah i don't don't sell them
sold by everything it's weird because
sometimes you do go watch a podcast or
something
and people are promoting it and you know
what in the podcast world i used to get
a lot of [ __ ]
if i had you on
once
and that was great
and then you shot a special and you came
on and talked about it they loved you
yeah there was no beast well you got to
do that to an extent but
when you just do uh like when people
were doing
like just weird things like uh when
somebody just comes in to sell a book
yeah i get [ __ ] yeah
[ __ ] yes you know when somebody comes in
to sell
a specific date or something yeah i
would get [ __ ] a little bit not about
what they tell me yeah but but like
think about it you put a special on
youtube
everybody will tell you including your
best friends they go you gotta do all
the podcasts you got to drive down and
see joey i mean i love doing this anyway
because i haven't seen you a while and
it's great but you got to do all that
[ __ ] because if you don't you're not in
the algorithm
and
i don't care how good your special is
it's getting [ __ ] a lot of love
doesn't matter bro you're not getting
eyeballs on that people are too busy
we're moving too fast if it's not right
in front of me i'm not going to watch it
you know but that's the reality of what
we do bro
i don't sell promotion for me i don't
know about you i i i cringe i listen as
a comic
that like jay davies
okay love him great guy such a
sweetheart jay davies was a puzzle for
me
you know jay davies promoted these rooms
and he got 500 people in there
just most of the women in the world you
don't you just don't know and he's a
good looking dude you know
but tiny but whatever the [ __ ] you know
he's uh [ __ ]
you know we when i first started living
in l.a i saw these people there's
another spanish comic well i don't know
how the [ __ ] he does he would get 300
people not gabriel like this is a
promoter kid that i don't even think he
does
that's an art in itself it's a [ __ ]
art but
uh the kid wasn't that good of a comic
but he did a great job promotions and i
remember i used to be jealous
like what do we need to do do i need to
get flyers and go to a mall and pat
because that sucks going to a mall hey
how you doing you want to come to a
great comedy show do it dude all that
[ __ ] i mean i would hire people maybe
but hand out [ __ ] i think i think right
now today you know what you do you get a
[ __ ] a a truck with a billboard that
drives up and down a street with your
[ __ ] face on it and saying joey diaz
that's the only thing i can think that's
not gonna work anymore either
think of how
think of
listen i remember when i got into i
still remember
selling neon
and you know the businesses you know my
job would just be to drop
a hundred flyers off a day i would get
ten calls yeah close three of them it
was automatic and some days if i didn't
get a call then the next day i get six
calls you know what i'm saying like
you're always gonna get three calls
but nobody would do that anymore like
nobody's gonna pass out flyers
nobody's gonna right now we have so many
different opportunities to promote yeah
and as a comic you're not going to get
anywhere unless you promote yourself
there's no
i [ __ ] was horrible at that i could
never you can't rely on traditional
media
no you can't do traditional what
exactly me i'm gonna be by the way i'll
be in san jose this weekend so come see
me thursday friday saturday san jose
improv have you done that club recently
oh no
no great club you've done it though
before oh yeah i've done it
but there's no more [ __ ] uh my
restaurants not there original joe's
closed oh really
so i was just going up to san jose
to go to original joe's then on the way
out of there you go to the airport
you go to the airport you get yourself
the three eggs with the steak
with the wheat toast forget about it i
go up there just because original joe's
in san francisco i couldn't get into it
it's a two-hour wait wow
why'd they close it down in san jose
because they don't know you have to i
don't even know if it's true i haven't
spoken to anybody up there i heard a
rumor that they were closing
just about the time covert hit
that san jose improv is a [ __ ]
landmark i've done it and i'm excited
i've done it in like two years i mean
san jose improv is a fun [ __ ] weekend
plus they got great martial arts schools
up there oh yeah bro i used to go to ak
aka the last time i would not the last
time but like a couple times back i go
to i go you'll love this i go to [ __ ]
uh i'm doing the improv and uh i go to
aka and and and
daniel cormier is there luke rockhold
and luke throws me headgear
now i was boxing so i had my mouthpiece
so i'm like [ __ ] i go i put my
mouthpiece in and i'm like hey guys
they're all killers and i'm a [ __ ]
idiot right so daniel cormier goes i got
him first i got him first and we're just
light sparring we're touching and stuff
like that and i've been boxing and i've
done enough martial arts to you know
and [ __ ] i'm hitting daniel and i'm
hitting him on the shoulder
and he's doing and he's doing this kind
of philly shell and just giggling as
he's coming at me and it's i may as well
hit you may as well punch the ocean
punch the [ __ ] weather if there's a
hurricane punch the weather punch the
hurricane that's about as much that's
about as much chances you have and i
don't know where he just grabs me double
legs me and and he goes he goes watch
this i'm gonna make him tap and he puts
his shoulder in my chest now i was a
wrestler okay i'm a grown man the
[ __ ] double legs me puts his
shoulder in my chest
i can't breathe i'm like uh and he goes
look at this look look look look yeah
and he's just just the weight i was
tapping like a balanced [ __ ] like
thumper my thumb
and then
no but i but then luco's and then me and
luke are moving around luke rockhold
okay one of the greatest middleweights
of all time 6-3
twenty at the time this is before he
beat the [ __ ] out of chris weidman all
right
and he does uh for sure enough he does
one of those [ __ ]
question mark kicks boom right in the
[ __ ] face my nose was black and blue
i i put it on instagram i had to go to
the [ __ ] i had to go get makeup and
put it on my [ __ ] nose because my
nose was i looked like bozo
but anyway the point is don't [ __ ]
around don't [ __ ] around with those guys
no i used to go to the other place and
do jiu jitsu with that guy that guy
turned me into a [ __ ] pretzel yeah
yeah john fitch was up there john fish
and that's what i want to get all these
people like listen i i spoke to you then
i talked about it
that i was talking to you about not
going on the road i'm like you know i'm
50. you're talking about being 55 before
coming in here and
going to new york city and it's like a
[ __ ] different animal i got an
eight-month-old at home too i'm tired
bubba i'm tired this is what i say to
people and i tried to listen man i would
have loved to
done this like ron white i would have
loved to do this till i drop yeah and
are you not going to are you thinking
about taking your foot off the gas and
not at all
not at all i'm just taking my foot off
the travel gas for right now okay
you know
there's an interesting story nobody even
heard of joshua
josh wolfe was with me in l.a since day
one since 97 one of the best guys on the
planet one of the best guys he's one of
the best [ __ ] people nobody ever
heard of josh wolf
in 2000 he got a deal
and as much as i remember that as much
as he wanted to do everything he
couldn't he was put in a bad position he
had three children he had three [ __ ]
[ __ ] no mother and no mother and he
[ __ ] worked around it and we i tried
to babysit him he would go do spots but
it was just not consistent enough
and he did what he could do he wrote
he wrote
and he made money he got on chelsea and
after 10 years the kids are gone
look what he's doing now yeah look what
he's doing now he does not take a week
off no you know
dave chappelle took time off to find
himself you know he took like 10 years
off yeah i'm not even taking time off i
took about a year and a half off
i just was burnt out from l.a yeah i
just wanted to decompress from what i
just happened yeah you gotta remember we
were just a bunch of [ __ ] kids
cracking jokes having a good time
[ __ ] around smoking pot and all of a
sudden the podcast world came and all of
a sudden there's a line to see us i know
it's so [ __ ] weird there's a line
yes from we couldn't sell a ticket
i remember doing the longest yard and
the [ __ ] movie being number two and
being out there the week afterward and
like like four people saw the [ __ ]
movie yeah and then i i go on my podcast
with felicia and i say that i mugged the
hooker and that night two week days
later i got a show at [ __ ] some place
you have a hundred people here what do
you stop like you know when club owners
call you and they go hurry up you got a
bunch of people when you get down
there's like 11 people you're like why'd
you say that to me if i'm like i just
want to get you to move when the guy
told me [ __ ] i have a hundred people
here i'm like if i get down there
and there's 10 people we're gonna have a
problem he goes joey you got 100 paid
people here
at 15 a piece
to me at that time it was more than 18
five yeah at 17 [ __ ] weeks when i was
fighting the kid i knew fighting kid was
a hit when the tsa dudes
were like bro fighting the kid
then i'm playing then then we're all
hanging out and i'm watching my kid play
soccer and a guy looks at me he's from
mexico he goes are you the kid
keep going i'm like bro what the [ __ ] is
this
what is this it was the craziest
experience of my life now while joey's
gone guys if you like comedy man tears
okay on youtube and if you really like
comedy this weekend thursday friday
saturday i'm at the funk in san jose
improv and then the weekend after that
i'm at spokane comedy club and the
weekend after that i'm at tacoma comedy
club and then if you're from [ __ ]
anywhere in the tri-state area october
13 14 15 i think that those the dates
i'm terrible i'm at the stress factory
in bridgeport [ __ ] so come get
some that's my plug
um look at this what is this it's a
little buddha thing
does he keep this on here has this got
some kind of like
this little his looks a little bit like
joey
yeah it's like the buddha version of
joey right there that's a great little
[ __ ] buddha i like that but no bro
and and i i'm happy you're here
because i want you to help me explain
this i mean we went from being
you know whatever 1500 a week comics
yeah nobody's exactly how much were you
making 1500 hours a week had to pay for
your plane ticket you know after two two
grams of coke and whatever i came home
with 300 hours like mad tv you know and
all of a sudden now your
your podcast is kicking
you know the money was the least of it
that's right i mean the money but i
could care less i never expected to make
any money no so i don't give a [ __ ]
about it
but what was happening people talking to
you
yeah people stopping you on the street
other countries
jesus christ i remember [ __ ] we did
acid church we did like two hits of acid
arie went to australia he checked in and
the guy goes i'm gonna walk him to his
room and laurie's like this doesn't seem
right when he checked into the hotel
on the way up the guy goes bro i got
acid that acid church was killing me
goes a week later i'm in australia
and this [ __ ] bellhop is walking me
up to the room to tell me he got acid
and then they saw the assets yeah
and then it wasn't just that it was
what was going on at the comedy clubs at
the store
the store went from being one of the
greatest clubs in california and by the
way you performed for 12 alcoholics at
[ __ ]
12 at night yeah nobody was at the
waiting room nobody was daddy criminal
was hanging out i mean it was
unbelievable and all of a sudden it went
to being the greatest comedy club in the
[ __ ] universe every [ __ ] night you
couldn't walk in there [ __ ]
celebrities
how many nights i go up there on a
tuesday and walk out the most famous
people right now i'm looking at [ __ ]
fame i'm like yeah what the [ __ ] is
going on at the store dr dre started
coming to the i mean
it was just [ __ ] it was shocking you
get recognized by famous people yeah no
it was insane like even sean penn i met
sean penn one time and he uh he goes and
john like ozama was there and he john's
a buddy and john goes you know brian's
uh brian's a comic and and i've never
told a story but it was i don't know if
but maybe he was being polite but sean
penn goes yeah of course yeah and i went
like i i i'm still excited about it
maybe he was just being that way but i
think he knew a little bit i think he
kind of like maybe it's seen maybe been
at the store that was the only thing or
maybe it's seen something i've done but
i was so [ __ ] excited i was like what
the [ __ ] show you all love this story
because we all relate to this when i
shot grudge match yeah like nobody said
hello to me right
like you know what i'm saying i walked
in there and people like who's this fat
[ __ ]
i did what i had to do and then i flew
out i mean the director knew me so he
spoke to me i knew him from the longest
yard so he bullshitted with me but
everybody else nobody said get to me i
mean hello cool jay was cool de niro was
cool as [ __ ] john bernthal that's how he
became brothers he's a great guy oh i
just met him he's a [ __ ] great guy
wow what a great song i'm like what the
[ __ ] is going on here and all of a
sudden i go to
adr
now nobody said hello to me on this set
when i got the hollywood makes you feel
invisible oh please but i didn't give a
[ __ ] i wasn't listen you know i was
invisible not hanging with them anyway
no i was invisible to start off with i
was born invisible and then you go to
hollywood and you're more invisible but
what people don't understand you go to
adr yeah so for people like us like i
came from [ __ ] yeah so here i am in the
[ __ ] set with the neighbor all cool
james stallone i'm like nobody's gonna
believe this when i go to hell nobody's
gonna believe this when i'm telling them
this story so i go to adr
dawg nobody said [ __ ] to me when i got
the adr
every producer was there
they had bowls of fruit
they had sandwiches
and they're like wow how can we do it
joey oh my god it's so great to see you
yeah and i'm like what the [ __ ] is going
on i went inside i did the adr when i
came back [ __ ] even more producers
were back there talking to me how you
doing blah blah blah and all of a sudden
i leave and i call somebody i think i
called john and i go john
i just wanna he goes you know why
because when they screen the movies
people were yelling your name in the
movie that's right i heard that i heard
about that and he goes i heard when you
came up on stage when you came on the
screen people they sent me with deniro
everybody i heard this yes you come on
and the whole [ __ ] theater goes
that's when you know that the audience
the people they're not watching your
movies bro they're watching podcasts and
they know you as a person
and you and they identify with you
because you know what's really important
as a comic to truly believe you're not
better than your audience and i know
that i know i'm not better than any
[ __ ] listening that's
that's the difference because when
you're in hollywood and you're treated
like royalty you forget that [ __ ] and
you're out of touch podcasting comedy
i'm [ __ ] hanging with people
afterwards i gotta talk to you about
[ __ ] you relate to
so so if i think i'm better than you
you're not gonna be laughing at me
because i'm gonna be talking at you from
here to here
and that that's the that was the x
factor i think that's the advantage that
you know and what i did i had this feel
like this i [ __ ] go to uh
sylvester stallone's daughters
are comedy fans great gals jersey girls
man like they grew up with all the money
but their their feet are on the [ __ ]
ground you know i'm sorry that that that
that they're getting divorced because
that's a good family man that's a good
family she's their mother uh jen
she's a real class actor
and and
stallone say whatever you want that dude
is a family man like he loves those kids
he loves he i was really impressed with
him but anyway i get to go to his house
now i go to his [ __ ] house to watch
the super bowl
i go to his house to watch the fights
i'm being invited
i walk in there i'm with frank grillo
i [ __ ] walk in there and uh you know
stallone knows frank and stuff but now
i'm in there and it's like now now i'm
getting this from stallone hey bry
i get excited now thinking about it
anybody who's young doesn't understand
this now watch this so now i'm hanging
out and and i and i hey you know you
know al well al pacino's right there i'm
like yeah hey how you doing looking out
i'm [ __ ]
talking and now i'm i'm talking to these
guys and i'm eating as we're talking guy
fieri's in the kitchen guy fieri's
making the food
flavor town's in the [ __ ] kitchen
making the food david blaine shows up
who i've known forever he starts doing
magic he's just hanging out
i got bill burr smoking a [ __ ] cigar
looking at all the [ __ ] wine and the
cigar collection say he's obviously
bill's there then now oh i'm sorry have
you met sugar ray leonard you met
because he's in here with michael
strahan they're just [ __ ] hanging out
i mean it's just it's legend [ __ ]
central it's legend central that's just
the beginning of it all
and i'm and i'm just sitting there
[ __ ] talking to the um world and then
i hear all this river off don't mess
around with this river
oh my up and i go well there he is
that's arnold schwarzenegger who's now
here at the party and it's just a little
just it's a little get-together of
legends and invisible boy over here and
and
under just behind my face i'm going
but i'm trying to be cool i'm trying to
have a conversation
it was so [ __ ] good and at one point
i'm standing there and [ __ ] it's
pacino
stallone
schwarzenegger and i don't know add
somebody else sugar ray i don't even
know if he was there but it doesn't
matter and they're all talking and me
and and me and i'm i'm darting in with
my little i just want to have a
conversation i'm darting him with my
useless little [ __ ] things i'm trying
to
you know you ever see a bird dog
you know and [ __ ] billboard walks by
and he goes you've been here for over an
hour get over it already
but dude i'm like i'm not over it i'm
not getting over it this was royalty
it's great those days those days of the
movie star the way we grew up like we
were talking about the gods
those days are over now bro
because the veil has been lifted because
now with the internet and new media you
can't create that persona
it's too it's too atomized it's too
fractured it's not like you know tom
cruise still got it and some of these
guys still got it but i don't think
we're gonna see
those that magnitude of movie star
anymore not with not with the way new
media is
now it's like now you know if you gotta
like if you're joe rogan with a podcast
good luck walking down the street he's
he's the new kind of
icon that way and all he does is talk
about you you're not seeing a character
you're seeing a real person you're
seeing the authentic [ __ ]
and there's something about authenticity
it used to be you created a persona
and we fell in love with that persona
that you only saw for five minutes on a
talk show once in a blue moon and you
better catch it or it's gone and you
better catch that movie because they got
all the lights and everything else now
now
you got to be on a podcast and if you're
not authentic
if you're not telling the truth you get
found out
because human beings can read behavior
human beings can see
whether you're telling the truth or not
they you can see it and when you're a
phony and you try to get by
you try to start selling something
you're on there for the wrong reason
you're doing a podcast for the wrong
reason
see ya
so it's it's it's it's in that sense i
like where we're at i like where we're
at too yeah
i'm happy you came down the [ __ ]
jersey [ __ ] second it's good to be here
brother what's the name of the special
man tears [ __ ] beautiful where you at
this weekend um this weekend i'm at the
san jose improv thursday friday saturday
i got spakan the weekend after that
specant comedy club have you done that
place no you got to do those clubs
tacoma comedy club beautiful washington
state i got warrants remember then why
does that bring me closer to you
i'll be i'll be out here in bridgeport
at the stress factory october 13 14 15.
or maybe it's 15 16 17. i don't know
look it up briancallen.com i appreciate
you brother i appreciate it i love you i
love you too congratulations on
everything thank you bro it's been a
tremendous couple of years i love you
[ __ ] stay black and i'll see you
monday tip top magoo and now for a word
for my [ __ ] sponsors
all right
it could be hard to find time to work
out i understand
but fit bod tailors and exercise program
to fit your goals
equipment and your schedule it's the
easiest way to work out listen you
download the app you're pressing some
personal information and every day by a
certain time they have a workout ready
for you they also have video tutorials
that make it easy
to learn a new routine and it varies
your routine for you so you don't have
to over train it's way cheaper than a
personal trainer and you get a full year
personalized workouts with fitbit for
less than the cost of one session with a
personal trainer so i'll know what
you're waiting for download this app
right now fitbot is easy to use on both
apple and android devices
keep your workout momentum going or get
the party started with personalized
workouts from fitbit that get tougher as
you do get 25 off your subscription or
try the app for free when you sign up
now at
fitbot.me
slash joey again that's fit by dot me
slash joey that's 25 of your
subscription or try it for free at
fitbit
dot me slash joey the joint is also
brought to you by draftkings i don't
know how many times i got to tell you
this is the season to be [ __ ] jolly
if you want to jump up and down this is
it between nfl football college football
the ufc playoff baseball i can't tell
you what else to [ __ ] do with your
time download the draftking sportsbook
app today
this week again i'm going to get you
five hours on any football game
if you win you get 203 bets instantly
plus you can add tails on the same game
parlays the more tales you ask the more
money you win but if you want more
action draftkings early win promotion
will knock your socks off it's simple
this sunday you've been on any other
felt team to win if your team leads by
10 any point during the game
you get paid instantly even if your team
loses who's better than draftkings
nobody download the draftkings
sportsbook app now and use promo code
joey to get 203 bets when you place flat
isles on any football team
that's code joey j-o-e-y only at
draftking sportsbook an official sports
betting partner of the nfl minimum age
and eligibility restrictions apply
see show notes for details now do me a
favor download the draftking sportsbook
app download the draftkings fantasy app
and go win some [ __ ] money i
want to thank draftkings i want to thank
betterhelp and i want to thank fitbot
but most importantly i want to thank you
savages for supporting the podcast stay
black i love you and i'll see you
[ __ ] saturday at the sony theater
or next monday
tip top magoo stay black
so
you